how much is a script worth it's a very
good question uh it
depends basically what it is that the
writer is trying to get out of it um a
script can be a tool a script can be a a
great Showcase of what a writer can
bring to Hollywood bring to the market
um but that's just one aspect of spec
screen writing where you're trying to
present yourself as a writer for hire uh
at which point a script has an unlimited
amount of potential in terms of price
because you can build a career off that
mindset if you're going in as a one-time
pop off script where you're going to
write something specifically that's
marketable and sellable you can probably
flip it for uh a cheap deal if you're
able to secure a purchase generally
you'll probably be offered an option
agreement which means that a company's
going to uh borrow the rights to it and
see if they can generate uh a film
adaptation from your script um if you're
one of the lucky ones who's able to sell
a script uh for purch purchase and
actually receive a check for it up front
um it's generally worth about 10 to 15%
of what the actual out-of-pocket budget
will be to produce the film and in most
cases what would that be what like for
for let's say a made for television
movie what could a screenwriter expect
to see for their uh budgets
uh a budget is a very relative term
because a budget is you you give a
budget
um for a group of financiers or or
pre-sell uh who you're trying to get
money from and you're going to give them
a certain number so that you can gain a
little bit more from them uh if you are
on set you might give a different budget
number so that you can uh uh avoid
certain issues potentially with uh
contractors maybe trying to take
advantage of you um tax codes uh unions
um so there's the a certain budget level
might be presented there um and then the
final budget that's actually released
after the fact could include whole
marketing components that were never
factored in early on uh so budget's a
pretty relative term so how much one
movie might be budgeted for versus
another is all over the map it depends
on cast it depends on uh how much uh
collateral was secured in
advance um it's kind of all over the map
sure but what could a screenwriter
expect to get for their like just just
bottom line like if someone says you
know should I really invest all this
time in in honing this craft of mine and
and and coming up with multiple drafts
what could I expect to see from one one
script my belief is this uh what a
screenwriter can really expect out of a
single
script uh I I don't think a screenwriter
should really look at it in that way I
think a screenwriter could potentially
get you know a couple thousand dollars
up to tens of thousands of dollars for a
single script if it just Nails it
screenwriting is really more of a it's a
craft um and it's a kind of a lifelong
investment I believe of time uh and I
think that a writer is going to make a
lot more money if they're writing what
Hollywood needs overall uh because then
they can become a go-to writer they can
become a go-to writer that uh production
companies like the ones that I work for
um are always in need of
that you know when we have a film that
we're developing we have a project that
we have funded uh we can call up a
writer that we know we trust who can
deliver that kind of content quickly and
we can churn a very quick deal $1
155,000
$25,000 uh for a couple of uh you know
drafts of a script um and that can be an
ongoing situation and you can write
three four scripts a year in that
scenario if you're writing on spec in
the hopes that Hollywood will just
perfectly align with what you're
pitching to them it's a very very very
tough daunting challenge to be able to
actually get a transaction on that I
would say slim to nil of making it
happen that's why I think it's more
important for writers if they're going
to write spec which is a requirement in
the beginning write what Hollywood needs
focus on those gold mine genres the
must-have content that the system wants
uh and use it as a sample of what you
can bring to the marketplace and what
your value is as a writer uh and then
you can become a go-to writer so and
answer the big answer to the question is
how much can you make it's all over the
map it's more about not looking at it as
a one-off uh how much can I make on this
script it's more how is this script
going to Aid my career as a writer which
a writer can make a very substantial
amount of money if they play the game
right sure but for a first time newbie
let's say 2000 really could be the
lowest like the low end of what they
could expect to see 2,000 could easily
be an like an option Buy in so 2000 like
a company might say okay there's there's
something to the script we like the idea
we're not convinced that anyone's really
interested or maybe they go you know we
just had an interesting conversation
with company XYZ last week and they seem
to like something like this maybe we put
an option on this script uh of $1,500
$2,500 as a as a courtesy of let's
borrow the rights for a period of time
so we can pitch it to this company and
then if a deal takes place fantastic the
writer gets a payout the production
company gets the script um if no deal
takes place it's much less risk for the
production company or the producer or
whomever is giving the option and so um
in those instances that might be the
best opt that might be the best
opportunity a writer gets on that script
right it's really uh hit or miss it's
really hit or
miss Scott we always hear about person
writing this dream script it's their
first project they've had it for years
and it just pours out of them in one
weekend how many times have you seen a
writer first time script actually be
sold or optioned never never I've never
personally seen it um and I think that
that's a fantastic dream scenario uh I
believe that those stories really stem
from writers who actually have a career
in motion um and they have contacts they
can reach out to and it's not that they
sit and actually write a screenplay over
48 hours it's that they have an idea and
they already have a team of people who
trust them because they've delivered so
many quality scripts in the past uh a
newbie writer from scratch uh throwing
an idea to a major studio and expecting
a check in the mail or or some uh big
contract with an agent I've never seen
it happen and I think that maybe a
script has moved from point A to point B
and has maybe moved up the channels by
the time that movie reached the screen
um I don't think it had any similarities
to the original idea and I'm not sure
that the writer received anything from
it either I've never heard of it so most
people that either sell or option there
were
what is this their third fourth fifth
time writing a script I mean when from
when you talk to people what seems to be
the general amount that they've gone
through the the drafts the actual
incarnation of a story I think you need
at least two to three ready to go uh
featurelength scripts or two to three
ready to go TV spec script ideas um that
are completely ready to present to the
marketplace um and that takes time to
get to but I think you need that in Your
Arsenal as a minimum to be taken
seriously by decision makers and to
Showcase your
skills how does a screenwriter peque the
interest of studios and decision
makers I
think screenwriters stand their best
chance of really getting noticed uh by
knowing what the business needs so it's
not coming in talking about how
passionate you are about the script it's
talking and speaking in a way that
answers to the needs of the production
company the producer the studio Etc um
it's there are tried and tested genres
that are
just they they just nail what the
business lives on and if you're if if a
young writer wants to come into the
business and really just get their
emails answered get their phone calls
returned it's being able to speak about
their project and have it answer to
those things it's it's going to be
saying I'm writing a a family film about
this I'm writing a film about this and
it's a very quick point it's not uh it's
you know never coming of age stories
it's never dramas it's it's happier
films it's it's the kinds of films you
see on a RedBox machine that's what
Hollywood needs to stay in business and
so if you're coming to the table
bringing uh opportunities for Hollywood
to continue staying in business they're
going to pay attention to you so if you
have that Indie drama coming of age of
let's say like a male Rebel who's trying
to find you know answers to life save
that for your own weekend project yeah
and and and never at any point am I
saying don't write dramas don't write uh
uh comedies don't write the coming of
age story if you have a fantastic idea
for a movie I think a writer should hold
on to just hold on to it wait like get
the commercial scripts out first get a
reputation of being a screenwriter who
can deliver what the system needs who
can write quickly who can write well who
can write within budget uh and get a
couple of actual paid gigs and you'll
get them uh if you go in the opposite
way saying I know what Hollywood wants
they want this they want these very uh
deep dramas Coming of Age dramas um and
forcing them to do that uh it's not
you're not going to get noticed but if
you come and giving them what they want
which are like tween girl family films
or uh Christmas movies with dogs um
women imp perel Thrillers these kinds of
things uh Hollywood pays attention to
you and once you are writing those and
once you're getting noticed for that
work then you have a collection of
contacts and you can say I have an
interesting idea could this work and
then you can present
those I want to go in more to some of
those story ideas as well but I just
want to play a hypothetical let's say
that you and your colleagues are here on
one side of the table and I'm a
screenwriter so what is this initial
meeting like what should I be bringing
with me what short what type of work
should I have done
ahead of time and even really how should
I be dressed to come to this meeting I
think a screenwriter should look at a
pitch meeting as just a a first date
it's uh it's not you don't have to come
in
with every you don't want to come off
with static onliners about what your
scripts are you want the conversation to
be organic you need to come in
professional you don't I mean you have
to dress professional and that can just
be uh casual smart you know that that
you would be in a bar in an evening or
something like that you know not not a
sports bar but someplace decent so you
know casual clothing um and just just
keep the demeanor light and easy going
you want the ideas to feel free flowing
you want them to feel organic always
have a cheat sheet with you but in truth
I mean just just treat it like a first
date like just let the conversation
evolve you want to be very receptive to
other people's ideas but really a pitch
meeting is about auditioning you as a
writer to see if you mesh well with the
company are your ideas in alignment um
if they're bringing suggestions about
changing the lead from a male to a
female are you comfortable with that uh
because those are the sorts of
situations that if you're under contract
and getting paid you'll have to uh
listen to and deal with and so they want
to make sure you're comfortable with
that and that uh you're you're in
Synergy together so keeping that
hypothetical meeting going what are some
red flags that I should be aware of that
I should be careful of certain phrases
that I should say or maybe even body
posture I mean something that's going to
make me seem like I'm not
agreeable I I always the best way to do
it the best way for me to fake
confidence we all have to fake
Confidence from time to time is um you
know always expect the best you know
they have no preconceived notions about
who you are as a writer uh and and vice
versa so don't always assume that
Hollywood is out to rip apart new
writers to take advantage uh we actually
we we love our writers and and scripts
are the foundation of great films and we
need them so we we are looking for the
next great writer we are looking to find
people we can mesh well with the best
way to come into a room be on time look
professional speak
professionally uh and when the decision
maker in the room or whomever uh
orchestrated the meeting uh jumps in
with an idea stop and listen to them and
if an idea is presented that you don't
agree with don't attack it leave it on
the table
don't don't counter it right away you
know just let the conversation kind of
evolve um I think you should always go
into a pitch meeting prepared with at
least 5 to 10 fleshed out ideas you can
keep that on a cheat sheet of paper if
you'd like uh and you don't have to
necessarily have all those memorized and
ready to roll you don't even have to
bring them up but if the conversation
moves into a direction of what else do
you have maybe the first two scripts
that got you the meeting aren't what
they want they want to see what else you
have you're ready to roll with that and
if you're reading one of the pitches if
you're giving one of the pitches and
they quickly say that's not really in
our wheelhouse we're not interested stop
and move on to the next one it's not
personal they just they want to find out
if you can deliver what they need so
summing it up just keep it light and
flexible yeah keep it very light and
flexible first a mentality you're just
trying to see if you mesh well together
uh do you communicate well are are you
having fun I mean you know don't you
don't have to pull a standup act or
anything like that but I mean you know
make it make it light make it easy uh it
is not a terrifying experience for them
so it does not need to be a terrifying
experience for you any any phrases a
writer should definitely not I'm just
thinking of a job interview no one wants
to say oh well I don't want to work over
time so something is there something in
the whole writer sphere that's probably
a red flag that someone should hold
their tongue on I think the biggest
thing a writer needs to avoid is um
entitlement in truth it's always be
willing to make your script flexible
always be open and receptive to new
ideas and completely new takes on your
screenplay however ridiculous or counter
they may feel um and and don't treat
your script like a baby even though
you've committed so much time and energy
into it uh it's just an object in the
eyes of everyone else uh and so you have
to be able to detach from it so don't
get too personal um key phrases I don't
think there's really any key phrases
necessarily
uh I would avoid trying to say I know
that XYZ studio is into these projects
right now or that this is a popular
Trend because in truth Hollywood's
planning movies out and series out two
three sometimes four years in advance um
so they're not really playing the trend
game that's just something that kind of
happens organically as content's getting
out there um so I wouldn't try to
reference that sort of stuff
either your advice to screenwriters is
to get passionate about what's cells I
know we talked about that earlier so for
them to I think your the description for
your book you were saying to basically
they should forget about comedies is
that correct or am I look comedies are
fantastic uh and and you would be
correct anyone would be correct if they
said comedies are very high grossing
popular movies they absolutely are um
the problem is the best way for a new
writer to really break into Hollywood
and build a career is to go towards the
independent space not the big studios
there's too much noise at the big Studio
level there's way too many barriers so
go to Indie Hollywood that's where I
work uh and that's where really most of
the movies and content that's where it
comes from so on the comedies
front Indie Hollywood is not just
thinking US and Canada we're not
thinking our domestic English-speaking
markets we're thinking Global we get a
lot of our money from overseas and the
problem with most newbie writers is they
want to write something like American
Pie a really runchy comedy or they want
to write a very smart comedy uh W with
you know high level humor and and you
know witty dialogue witty dialogue costs
a lot of money to dub social nuances in
Russia or India or Japan are not what
they are here not every country in the
world celebrates Thanksgiving and
understands what the Super Bowl means um
there are there are so many subtleties
to the international marketplace that
even if you nail your comedy script and
make it wide enough for an
English-speaking audience to understand
that's a very limited part of the world
and the way a Hollywood executive or the
way a producer will read that is that's
a very limited uh cross-section of money
and I'm missing out on a lot of other
Revenue that can come in so comedies are
great just keep them in your back pocket
so I'm taking from your the Amazon link
for your book uh writing for the green
light how to make your script the one
Hollywood notices which is out in March
it's out in March yes great okay
congratulations thank you um and so you
say that instead you would encourage
them to write family films with with kid
Heroes action films for aging male stars
and female driven Thrillers yes those
are three of what I call the gold mind
genres yes yes and and one thing I
noticed is sort of the socioeconomic
levels of all of these films when you
say like a woman imp Peril it's never in
a bad apartment it's always in a really
nice place so it seems like a lot of
these there has to be a certain almost
standard of living people don't want to
see I mean just just from what you see
cells nothing personal or someone's
certain taste but it has to be almost
this upper middle class yes family and
and even if it's a murder mystery or
something there always has to be that
level why that's so fascinating that's
where the biggest cross-section of the
purchasing Marketplace is in this
country and throughout the world um
that's where uh adverti advertisers are
are are seeking to get their uh you know
advertisements in front of that audience
that makes sense that's if that's who's
buying things right exactly but why
wouldn't they want to see they want to
see people of their own thing in a story
they want to see someone at their level
of their sort of social strategy or
their idealized level yes ah okay
interesting interesting yes uh I mean
movies and television it's fantasy we
all want to we we watch it because we
identify with these characters but but
they are living out something that we're
not uh they're experiencing something we
don't get to uh for the female driven
Thrillers I mean a lot of female driven
Thrillers actually answer questions that
are more fantasy what if I had you know
uh been with that guy what if I had made
that decision instead and they sort of
answer what could have happened in those
scenarios um the the tween films those
are those are fantasies for younger kids
where they get to go live this big
adventure um you know and the the male
action star they're just fun but they
really speak to male audiences because
it's the ultimate you know alpha male
doing all the things it's the Delta
Force hero uh that secretly works on a
farm in the middle of Nebraska or
something like it speaks to Middle
America and it speaks to a big
cross-section of the world and a
screenwriter trying to make films for an
overseas audience what should they keep
in mind let's suppose they realize that
a large portion of Revenue is coming
from overseas should they start uh try
to Target stories and make them more I'm
not sure what your phrasing is of it but
more ethnic or keep it still very
Americanized it's okay to be
Americanized um it's okay to be very
true to I mean whatever country you live
in and are writing screenplays for you
know if you're living in England and
want to write screenplays for the
American Market or anything but but um I
I think the biggest trick for a newbie
writer is not to assume they understand
how the international marketplace works
because that changes all the time so the
best way to get ahead of it is basically
just stay neutral um keep themes very
Universal uh and then whenever it comes
to a very specific targeted element like
Thanksgiving uh American football you
know some
colloquialism um always see if there's a
way to replace it maybe maybe switch out
American football with soccer maybe
instead of Thanksgiving make it
Christmas um that way it's a little bit
more balanced and the world can identify
with it but at the same time I mean you
know I think most screenwriters are also
just Avid film fans and I love a foreign
film as much as the next person so if
I'm watching a movie as long as it's
true to that country um and I understand
the themes behind it I accept it an
American content does travel the world
the best so let's take another
hypothetical and let's say one writer
has a script about a girl that's in high
school and she wants to make sure that
she's the one that's voted for prom
queen and she's kind of has a rival
that's similar level as she and then
there's another script where it's about
a foreign exchange student who's a
little out there and maybe she's an
introverted writer and it's not as you
know she's maybe not on that same sort
of high school level which one would you
suggest that someone I mean it seems
like the answer is obvious but why why
why the high school prom queen I think I
I mean I'm not attacking you but I'm
just curious why do people want to see
these very sort of cookie cutter films
when there's a more of a flavorful range
out there in general it's because we if
you're going to a grocery store and
you're purchasing a product you know
what you're getting in the end and
that's kind of the idea when you're
watching a movie when you're going to
transact on a movie whether you're
buying a ticket um getting a copy on
Amazon or or some other you know
transactional VOD service you're looking
for an emotional experience and you want
one that's best going to cater to the
one you're looking to feel now actually
I would offer a third option in this
which would be instead of the high
school I would take the high school
script over the foreign exchange one
hands down but I would take it and we
would probably Rebrand that and make it
Junior High and make it more focused on
a tween girl audience knowing that 9 to
12 year old girls are the most likely
audience to be renting movies and buying
movies on some like iTunes Amazon or
other platforms uh and I I would see
bigger numbers doing that and I'd make a
really nice pink poster see this is how
we're talking it's you come in with an
idea and then we target an audience we
know we need to hit uh and then we we
create a concept around that and I can
already see the key art in my head and I
would go talk to my teams about doing
that I know how much money we can make
internationally with a movie like that
and we would go then have either take
that writer and have them rewrite it or
we go hire a writer we've had experience
with with to write the movie we now just
created in 2 minutes and keeping this
film um who's the protagonist like
what's her makeup and who's the who's
the evil character and who's the guy
they're fighting in a tween girl movie
the protagonist is a young girl who is
not the most popular girl in school um
she needs to be uh you know fun average
but a you know like has all the
potential to be great but she just
doesn't see it in herself yet and
there's always that cool girl who has
all the cool friends and who makes fun
of her and things are always happening
that are uh you know it's never going
her way she always makes a fool of
herself in front of the boy she likes
Etc and then she has some kind of secret
characteristic a a magical ability maybe
somebody comes to her and she's suddenly
granted a day where she can make dreams
come true maybe maybe some element like
that that it's a special skill that only
she has she she tries to use it to
become like the girl she thinks she
wants to become which is the
antagonist um and ultimately realizes
that she doesn't want to become like
that person she's far better than her
and can become something completely
different and at the end of course she
just realizes it's herself she's just
evolving blah blah blah blah blah but
that's the story that just means a lot
to them and who's the guy that they're
they're both Rivals for the guy is
usually it differs um there can be the
really cute boy that all the girls like
and that our protagonist just somehow
has a chance encounter to meet with and
has some kind of random reason to be in
communication with him they're neighbors
uh he's he's trying to use her for
something and then realize he has
feelings for her through the process or
he's just kind of the Arrogant guy that
all the girls like and there's actually
kind of the goofy friend guy who does
live next door whom everyone over looks
and then he then our protagonist
realizes that she this this guy's
actually fantastic and he's like the
hero at the end and they they get to go
off and make everyone else jealous I'd
rent this movie yeah it's good that's
you'd rent it rent it a lot of young
girls would rent it and they would watch
it over and over and over again and we
have a lot of movies like that here and
it's amazing to me how many middle-aged
women come in middle-aged men too and
they go my daughter just loves this can
I get a free screener copy just so I can
like stop paying for it on red box or
something else so they're so the they
it's through
identification that that that's what's
getting them and to live out that
fantasy and so most people are going to
be that girl in junior high or or that
guy friend that was maybe overlooked and
so they identify yeah they identify
that's where we're getting that and
here's what's interesting about it the
young girls younger girls want to see
the Junior High girl because she's a
little bit older than what she is or
she's very close in age girls at that
age are very obviously self-conscious
they want to know what they're what
other girls are doing if they're behind
so that they can get ahead um boys boys
at that age are also very curious uh and
they boys at that age secretly really
like those movies too they like the
really feel-good movies um they
understand these experiences and they're
they get just as emotionally drawn into
them as well um boys at that age will
not identify with a male version of that
boys at that age would act would rather
go see an action film or something like
that if they want the male skew so
they're not going to go after like a
male version of that younger boys will
like ages 6 to 11 but like a tween aged
boy doesn't want to see tweenage boys
he'll watch a tweenage girl film and lie
to his friends that he did or he wants
to go see a rated R action film and
that's actually where the other big
genre is the uh aging male comeback
film you also write in your notes for uh
your book writing for the green light
that you want to do your best to present
a pitch without looking desperate yes
and you say that
looking desperate may get you a raw deal
or it may may not be as favorable I'm
curious what are signs of desperation
and why why would being Uber confident
get you a better deal when it's still
the script is still the same but maybe
the screenwriters is a little unsure of
themselves uh when I refer to pitch
meetings and I I kind of explained pitch
meetings that the best way to handle a
pitch meeting would be treating it like
a first date
um the same rules apply in any facet of
business and they apply when you're
pitching your screenplay or just
presenting it in some way uh if you're
on a first date and you look desperate
you just you give off this really bad
negative vibe um you're not confident in
yourself you don't believe in the work
or maybe you're you're when you're
desperate about something you're trying
to push the work as it is and you're not
listening to how the other party maybe
is kind of saying we'd prefer it a
little bit more over here we're open to
the idea but we'd prefer it a little bit
more like this this and if if an
individual is shying away from that and
desperately holding on to what they feel
it should be initially um they just
don't present a very good image of
themselves as being collaborative
desperation can also come across of an
individuals coming to me let's say and
um it's a film Market or a a film
festival I'm not the person they need to
be pitching to and I might explain that
and I might give them a business card of
the right person to go talk to but they
continue
pitching their script to me and I'm not
the guy who can help them uh and it just
kind of has this Vibe of okay look I'm
not saying it's a negative against the
screenplay but you don't necessarily
seem to understand the dynamic of how a
business works and who to talk to in
that business and and all that it's it's
just it's a it's a slight little thing
where um over time too many of those
start to kind of push you know your
opportunities away from you whereas if
you do the opposite uh you force
yourself to fake confidence um and
there's a lot of ways you can do that
you uh are only you know you you truly
try to listen to what people are telling
you and and approach the business in a
way where you're presenting your script
and your ideas um in a in a confident uh
happy fun way and you're quick to say
you know if that idea doesn't work for
you don't worry about it or or you're
being a little bit more um easygoing
with your work uh that presents more of
like okay this person understands that
Hollywood's an evolving thing the script
is never really written until the Final
Cut of the movie is finished uh you know
all those sorts of nuances so so again
let's say I'm in front of um the person
that is the decision maker what are some
signs that are going to give me uh the
appearance of confidence even if I'm not
because sometimes I think Uber
confidence to me is a turnoff I'd
actually rather see more of a real
person but I know a lot of people don't
subscribe to that same belief but what
are some things I know you said being
too quick to be defensive sounds like
that that shows that you're wounded by
the notes and that maybe it's it's too
much for you to handle but just you're
saying again keeping it light it sounds
like well you bring up a really good
point uh you're correct you can faking
confidence doesn't necessarily mean uh
being narcissistic uh and I I don't mean
to come off that way and have that uh no
be but it's it's a good point you're
making you're correct to fake confidence
it's more about just realizing
presenting work um you're presenting a a
blueprint of what could be a movie but
that blueprint is open to everyone
else's ideas as well uh so you're
correct in saying don't take any changes
or adjustments to heart don't be too
defensive about your work um but also
you got to watch the offensive part too
and not be too in love with your work
not be too uh self-absorbed with it and
um recognize that you're not the only
writer in Hollywood uh and that you see
it more as a collaboration of
personalities working together to get a
script in Motion versus just you as a as
a sole uh contributor to the script so
it's just a it's just a shift of how to
view the overall relationship I guess
looking desperate is you know going to a
film Market a film festival and just
pitching your ideas to anybody and
everybody who will give you 30 seconds
of their ear uh looking desperate is
being in an elevator and then realizing
you're next to somebody who who kind of
related to somebody else who has a
connection to a decision maker and then
pitching them your idea awkwardly in a
in a in an elevator you know uh th
that's looking desperate it's it's
chasing Trends it's it's inventing
scenarios that just aren't real uh
business opportunities for your
work Scott let's say that I don't have
access to your book and I don't have
access to a lot of other things so where
would I find um what sells You'
mentioned earlier go to a red box see
what titles are on the front of the um
the front on the lower part yeah really
front to or or that augment big Studio
titles yeah but continue sorry oh
interesting okay I did not know that
okay so then take take go to your local
Red Box peruse the titles that are out
there in the front if that it's been a
while since I've been to a red box so is
that how it's set up where you have the
the films right there yeah I I think
look it's it's a really it's a huge
question to say what should I write and
I I I do my best to answer that in the
easiest way for new writers in my book
um and and I I try to break that down
the best I can but I mean it's it's a
really big question uh and the thing I I
certainly don't want to see any
screenwriters uh run into is just
feeling like they have to blindly guess
I I try to answer that in the book but
if you don't have access to the book um
the best advice I could give to a
screenwriter is yes you can go to a red
box machine machine used to be
Blockbuster but those all turned into
cell phone stores um you can go to Red
RedBox machine look at the independent
films on there so independent would be
the the family titles at the bottom look
for the liveaction ones usually with a
dog or an animal on them um and then
also look at the big Studio films that
are kind of you know throughout the
machine you'll see them in different
spots whatever a big Studio film is look
to the ones that are like right next to
that or get on Netflix and find a big
Studio Movie in in the lineup and then
look at the independent movie you've
never heard of that's next to it that's
the independent Hollywood Zone that's
where I work those are the scripts that
were in need of that's that's where I
think you're going to get your best
indicator as to the genres that work the
genre themes you're going to see uh the
number of cast members the all that
information and another source you could
do is if you have writing experience if
you have a couple of screenplays you're
confident in that you think uh are
interesting for Hollywood uh I would
call up uh development agents creative
Executives um I would you can find their
information in several different sources
LinkedIn or or any platform like that is
a great way to kind of Kickstart it uh
but contact them and basically say I'm
interested in writing a script uh what
works and if it's interesting to you
could I write a treatment and present it
to you and then write it for you you
know you could do that as as a scenario
and just go direct to the source and
write something for them I mean I think
that's actually the big question a lot
of newbie writers have is how do you get
from point A to point B my whole
reasoning for the book was answering
that question the best I could that's
information I certainly didn't have
about the movie business when I left
Film School um nobody really tells you
how to bridge that gap of okay I I don't
know anybody how do I build a career out
of anything uh producers in Hollywood
knows they already know what sell
creative Executives in Hollywood they
know what sell they all have really
great ideas another way to do it is go
try to talk to to them and say look I I
want to write scripts um I'm looking to
connect with somebody who knows what
sells I'll write whatever script you
want me to write uh you lead the way I
mean there's there's a lot of ways you
could I guess uh really figure out
what's going to get you some attention
and that would lead to just a initial
five- minute meeting I mean if if
someone presented themselves
professionally on the phone and and and
seem flexible do would that actually
then open the door to okay well we'll
meet with you for 5 minutes to see a
spec script that you have I mean it's
worth it's definitely worth a five-
minute call I think I think a true
producer in Hollywood somebody who's
well connected a creative executive in
Hollywood if they're working for a
company that you know they're
comfortable with but maybe they're not
having that opportunity to work on the
stuff that they want to but they have
all the connections you wish you had um
that that's a great link and yes if you
went out to them and basically
approached them and said I have three
scripts of this genre um I would love to
present them to you and I'm not trying
to get you to buy these scripts uh if if
you're interested fantastic but I'm not
trying to get you to buy these I just I
want to work with somebody and develop
something from scratch you're a creative
executive you know what sells you have
contacts and I'm sure you have story
ideas that you just don't have time to
put together let me be that you know fix
in your system I'll get you the script
you need and then we can go hit the
marketplace together uh and that goes
into fakeing confidence it's a scary
scenario to be in but um if you if you
are able to approach that and basically
present that kind of conversation
uh you will actually see quite a few
doors open and a lot of emails answered
likeability versus Raw Talent what
percentage do you think gets people uh a
deal talent's important I think
likeability is very important I think uh
persistence and uh the ability to work
hard are the most important I think
likability gets the door open likability
is a crucial factor in terms of just
being able to walk your way into a
scenario get people to listen to you uh
and take your ideas and your talent
seriously but that's part of it's that's
the first part of the equation it's the
most important part of the first step of
the equation but once you have that
opportunity presented to you you have to
follow through with a lot of hard work
and uh Talent uh you can if you're not
100% confident in your own talent and no
artist ever is um the that's where
faking confidence kind of comes comes
into play there's sort of tricks and
things you can do to sort of push things
more in your favor I outlin that a bit
in the book where I list out all the
things that readers hate about spec
scripts and it's basically just an
overview of everything that is a is a
turnoff to them it's an indicator of a
writer who just doesn't get what the
system needs um and and why it's
important not to have any of those
elements and they range from everything
of uh too many characters in your script
uh to grammatical errors and things like
that very fixable things but if you if
you make sure to get rid of as many of
those you're just weighing more odds in
your favor of getting your script taken
seriously but ultimately the biggest
reason that uh a script is not seen to
fruition it's not it's not made what is
it usually the out of all the spec
scripts in Hollywood the reason it's not
made to fruition is just people writing
the wrong thing so it's there's so many
my view is this it's like there's The
Stereotype in Hollywood that there's
there's every every other waiter you
meet is like has a screenplay on the
side every real estate agent's writing
something on the side and in truth like
that that's reality uh a lot of people
come here with big Hollywood dreams and
want to write that great screenplay and
people just kind of go oh well you know
they're not talented they're writing bad
scripts certainly there's a lot of bad
scripts but at the same time there's a
lot of very talented people who just
aren't writing the right things so
they're they're not writing the right
things they're not writing what
Hollywood needs and they're not
presenting their work in the way that it
needs to be presented to get doors to
open so if they just shift a few of
those elements if they write what
Hollywood needs which are gold mine
genres as we outlin in the book if they
if they present their ideas in a way
Hollywood needs to hear them which is
about pitching your story in a way that
is this is how my script helps your
company this is how my script uh answers
that that need in the Hollywood System
uh and then if you just kind of get
yourself out there at the same time like
that's how you really do it it's
building it's not it's not selling a
one-off script it's building a
career Scott how do you negotiate a
contract without an agent so let's say
we've gotten to a point where ready to
sign there's been many drafts the
screenwriters met with numerous
people and and my answer is here they're
not to knock agents agents are great
people and they they're vital in this
business but for new writers starting
out um I I have seen too many talented
writers sign a deal with an agent um
actors too and they just they get stuck
in a scenario area where they can't get
out of and the belief is that you need
an agent to negotiate your contracts for
you or open doors for you and it's
really not true um how you negotiate
your own
contract it seems scary because
contracts are very scary documents
they're legal and there's all these
terms and definitions that are overly
worded in truth if you can read a menu
at a restaurant you can read a contract
and if you can ask the waiter for Mayo
on the side instead of on the burger you
can negotiate a deal Point like it's
it's not any different and a contract is
nothing more than common ground it's a
piece of paper that explains how you and
a production company or producer are
going to work together what are the
terms uh and all that so you basically
just read it you look for the elements
that make sense to you and that you
agree with you highlight or red flag
anything that seems awkward or intrusive
or you don't understand and you throw it
back at them and you say answer these
questions and we'll continue the
conversation if you're unsure of it you
can always hire a lawyer and yes you'll
have to pay for a lawyer but hiring a
lawyer on a one-time contract who's only
working for your better interest whereas
an agent is working for dozens of
writers better interest more importantly
they're working for their own interest
um you're going to get all the attention
you need you're going to see all the
details you need to see in there uh and
you will have a a valid source kind of
vetting out all those major questions on
your behalf um when to sign the deal is
there's no real formula to it it's
basically just making sure that you're
clear on all the the requirements you're
comfortable with the money uh or
whatever uh transaction you're going to
have in there you understand the flow
the workflow uh what action item you
have to do will trigger what action item
on the other side and you understand uh
when the term will conclude um and how
to exit it uh or anything along those
lines right so let's say we're at this
hypothetical meeting and I'm looking
over this contract and I'm like hm you
know what let me see perpetuity what's
that mean let me look that up you know
what actually can I take this with me
and and have an attorney look at it
because I don't I'm not there's a couple
things the scenario let's say you would
say yes and they would give the person
what a week to find someone and have
them review it make an appointment and
then come back to you and have any
changes oh yeah and and in truth I've
never been in a scenario where where uh
I've seen a contract handed to somebody
and they're expected to review it and
sign it on the spot okay uh so you never
have to worry about that um usually
let's take a hypothetical pitch meeting
you know you come in you're you're the
writer you show the a good amount of
confidence you treat it like the first
days we talked about um it's casual yeah
yeah it's casual it's fun you present
your ideas they seem to be in alignment
with everyone else you end the
conversation in a fun way which is like
you know well we seem to be in alignment
with a lot of our ideas as I just said
and uh I I really look forward to being
in touch with everybody you send a
polite followup they express some
interest Etc you bounce emails back and
forth and then when they're ready to say
you know we'd like to bring we'd like to
hire your services on this movie or we
have a movie idea that seems in
alignment with some of the projects
you've written we'd like to see what
kind of a treatment you could write for
us that'd be your first option and that
would be kind of a they would send an
agreement to you a word dock get the
word document and you review it um and
you'll notice that when you type
anything in it or if you adjust any
words it'll suddenly turn red on the
screen and it's called redlining it and
you get to put all your notes in there
you can add comments you can add
questions or if you have a lawyer you
can forward that word document to them
they'll do the same thing for you and
they'll probably do a a crazy job with
it uh called making it bleed so to speak
and um they'll you just email it back to
the party and you can bounce the
contract back and forth several times
and you again it's it's you're just
highlighting the points uh that you have
questions about or your lawyer does or
your manager um and you uh you wait for
their response and they'll give on some
things and they won't on others and you
just kind of see what you're comfortable
with right so then this theoretical
Email exchange probably with numerous
people cced on it would be like you know
we agreed to terms 1 through five but um
seven we want to change it to this and
then SE please see attached kind of a
thing okay interesting um so it's not
where hey why don't you come on in great
here's a pen sign this oh sorry you
don't agree with this well let's talk
about it you would have time to review
it you could review it on your own terms
where wherever you are show other people
it's not this high pressure thing where
it's like buying a car something it is
not a high pressure situation and uh you
should never
feel that you are being pressured into
signing something ever so it's it's if
you feel uncomfortable with the scenario
um and they're not comfortable with you
they're not comfortable emailing you a
contract or they're not comfortable uh
letting you show it to an attorney uh
they're probably not a company worth
doing business with any legitimate
company any legitimate uh entity uh is
going to totally understand that that
flow and they're going to be
understanding that you need to have it
reviewed and it takes time it's not like
a back and forth thing that happens in
in two minutes they got a lot of stuff
on their plate you do too so you know
take it I would say three days is a good
turnaround that you receive it maybe
send a thanks email just to let them
know you received it uh and then take
two or three days to really read through
it and make sure you understand all the
terms and then and highlight the
questions that you have and just send it
back great so in terms of the studio
being flexible that's a good sign for
the screenwriter as well to see that
it's not high pressure in terms of but
but have you ever seen it where it draws
out and then if finally it's like look
you need to make it decision here I
normally see it draw out the most when
an agent's involved uh agents tend to I
call them wedges lawyers can be wedges
agents can be wedges again these are
very smart Savvy people who are very
valuable later stages in your career but
when you're starting out your first
couple of deals you really don't need to
deal with them intently um I've seen a
really tal I've seen really talented
writers have an option on the table have
a deal on the table I've seen the
company want to work with them and I've
seen the writer be very accommodating to
it and then I've seen agents interfering
calling conference calls demanding crazy
demands and increasing the money like
it's kind of stupid numbers where
they're not even really gaining all that
much for the amount of time they're
really putting in there it's more just
like the principle of just pushing
pushing pushing to get the most
exorbitant deal possible and what
happens is those companies will just
kind of say you know what we're done
we're we're not going to deal with you
anymore and uh I talk about this in the
book actually is I overheard a speaker
phone conversation exactly like this
where the creative executive on a film
said you know what I really like uh the
script I really like the writer uh I'm
not dealing with you anymore and I'm
canceling this deal and then of course
the writer is just like I'm sorry the
agent was just like wait wait you know
like let's come up with a deal and uh uh
they just canceled the call and that
writer got screwed because the agent
came in and kind of fouled up the deal
since an agreement is about Common
Ground if you have the writer and you
have the company they both have a reason
to be working together they can find
common ground and and look it's always
going to be you know you're always going
to have to fight a couple of points here
and there but it's it's always going to
be common
ground going back earlier to something I
said about um their first script A
writer's first script being the the do
all and end all and you said to have
several like two or three yeah can you
talk about those two or three scripts
that that writer should have in their
Arsenal yeah um an important fact factor
with that uh most writers want to
showcase how talented they are and so
they'll write two or three scripts that
are completely different they want to
showcase that they can do drama that
they can do uh family that they can do
something else um not only should a
writer focus on the gold mine genres
it's really important that they focus
that those two or three scripts are the
same Gold Mine genre and the the thing a
writer will say instantly is w i get w i
get like known just for writing that one
thing and the answer is yes you'll get
branded and that's a great problem to
have that means that you're going to
become one of those writers that becomes
a go-to oh this guy can really write
family tween girl films you know and
it's like that's the person they're
going to go to when they need a writer
who can do that um if you write too many
you know different ideas if you present
all your scripts all of a sudden then uh
you know a creative executive might go
this is a great script do you have
anything else like that so that they can
see if you're consistent with your ideas
with your talent and if you can bring
fresh ideas to the same Gold Mine genre
so are you saying that let's suppose I'm
again the screenwriter that I should
have three twin girls or I could have
one tween girl one aging superhero and
the other one um a family Christmas
story where the dog is lost and then
comes home again I would say I would say
focus on one if you want if you want uh
we we have family Christmas dog
Adventure is one of my one of the gold
mine genres doesn't have to be a dog
doesn't have to be Christmas either but
it's more a holiday themed animal film
that's very very family safe you can
write three of those so you could change
the holiday you could maybe change the
animal um but you got to stay in
alignment with that if you want to do
tween girl films you got to do tween
girl films all the way maybe they can be
you know in a different state uh maybe
their but their problems pretty much
have to be the same in one maybe it's
magic where dreams can come true
magically one day another could be that
uh uh her her sweet 16 present I don't
know if it's a car or something like
that that uh some dream scenario like
that uh actually has the magical ability
to travel I I'm just coming with random
ideas but it's like you just have to
have fresh innovative ideas to the same
Gold Mine genre then you become
consistent at that and you become
branded as a writer who can deliver that
fast and Innovative uh and it's kind of
like being an actor who gets typ cast
talk to any actor an actor who's type
cast that's like a a dream scenario
because they're the first person that a
casting director will call and you can
do that as a writer too so get that
Indie Coming of Age which is part Your
Story Part someone else's story out of
your system write it maybe put it
somewhere and then start going to the
red box seeing what's you said to the
left at the bottom or something around
there just around it yeah just around
the big Studio movies uh you'll see the
family dog adventure movies at the
bottom there's always going to be kid
movies with animals in them at the
bottom several of them usually and then
if you look more in the middle Zone
you'll see the big Studio whatever a big
Studio action film in the next to it
you'll see the coming of age I'm sorry
the uh the Aged male action film
comeback film you'll see that kind of
movie next to the big Studio One choose
one you love choose one that you feel
gives you the most creative ability a
women apparel Thriller I mean like
people will knock at these genres like
oh they're so commercial Etc get into
them like really get into a young girl's
head a male writer who can get into a
young girl's head and effectively pull
that off like you're talented and you
will get noticed if you are a a a young
female writer and you write a a kick-ass
action movie for a Coming of Age male
actor you'll get attention and if you
can do that consistently like you'll get
noticed going back to the women in Peril
what are some some scenarios where the
Peril is not too dark you know I've
watched Lifetime movies for years and I
I actually enjoy them as much as you can
kind of see the cliche scenario that
happens all the time but what are these
these women and Peril stories how do
they usually end up of course and and
what's too dark you don't if it feels
more like a Law and Order SVU episode
that's too dark you want it you can do
like a don't take my baby movie which is
like an adoption scenario that's gone
wrong but the baby cannot be in like
physical
Jeopardy uh you can have the the
Vigilante female who has been wronged by
the system and uh she has to take
justice into her own hands you know she
can she can
go you know take revenge on males but it
it it's not like a murder spree it's
more like uh she's going to get back at
them by hurting them where it hurts most
and I don't mean to knock to the balls
I'm talking about like ruining their
business showcasing them as a cheater to
their spouse you know this kind of stuff
ruining their lives in that sense like a
a smart tactical strategic way of doing
it uh that's more the the theme behind
it and this female and Peril again who
is she like what cuz she can't be from a
bad neighborhood right she has to be
still middle class college educated nice
girl maybe did a couple bad things right
we we've all done a couple bad things
and she's very reflective of just the
average human experience but she should
be you
know youngish middle-aged maybe um and
it's essentially just she did all the
right she made all the right decisions
in life she did everything that she was
supposed to do uh and somehow or another
life has just kind of wronged her the
man that she married turned out to be a
a abusive or a cheater or maybe he's
corrupt and he's getting arrested for
embezzlement uh she's doing all the
right things to uh help a young mother
in need with her infant uh and then it
just turns into a nightmare um she makes
one mistake uh thinking that it's not a
big deal um and she's just following her
heart and then it turns out to be a
nightmare it's like the reverse Fatal
Attraction scenario I mean it's it's all
kinds of stuff like that but it they
should not they should be reflective of
just a normal noral person who's just
doing the right thing who just gets
caught up in something that they never
expected to have happened to them and
it's even better when uh they're doing
what they think is right and the system
wrongs them and why wouldn't we want to
see someone that's a little bit off that
maybe we wouldn't be but it's kind of
interesting like you see someone at the
bus stop and you think wow I wonder what
their life is like why wouldn't most
people want to see that what because
it's not reflective of them and they're
scared of it I just find that
fascinating they just yeah can't
identify with it as easily and so if
they can't truly put themselves into
that lifestyle and truly see how this
character could be you
know like an evolution of themselves uh
it's just more difficult to grasp on to
it's either got to be like something
that they see that they they could have
been uh something they wished they could
have been something along those lines
those are really the stories that that
really they they talk about like the the
characters more interesting and
the reason why is because we all wish we
had that bite where we could just go say
those things and do those things and
behave that way it's an evolution of
what we wished we could see it's kind of
a fantasy but but there has to be
something within that character we
identify with even somebody as evil as
like Alex and A Clockwork Orange or
something like that you know it's it's
at the end of the day it's there has to
be some element in that character that
we can see uh and that's what it
is Weir is mar to go to acquire movies
so we produce um about 20 to 25 feature
films on our own each year uh we produce
those primarily for major networks here
in the United States uh and we also have
major output deals with global companies
like tf1 in France uh Etc so it's like
we kind of know our end user very very
well so we are able to put money into
films and and have a home for those but
we also acquire another 25 to 35 movies
per year
sometimes more as we're we're learning
for
20156 um and we look in a like a variety
of sources to find those we get
submissions blindly from producers uh we
talk to the major agencies who represent
producers who are making films on spec
we work with producers Representatives
um we will basically find any Source who
has access to new content and go look
the biggest misconception Young
filmmakers have is I'm going to go
produce movie spend a lot of money on
credit cards or something else um and
just get it to film festivals and
everything will magically take place
after that the truth is like it it
doesn't happen that way some companies
will buy movies from film festivals uh
there are some film festivals where
movies are going to find a home but most
of the major film festivals whether it's
Toronto can etc those movies are already
being represented uh they're looking to
Showcase it for foreign clients they're
looking to Showcase it for
uh rights overseas or or limited rights
in the US like they're being represented
though can we talk about focus groups
yeah because you you were in the mindset
of a young tween girl and I can tell you
it sounds exactly like all of us women
when we were younger we so how did you
know all this how what type of questions
are asked what's going on at these focus
groups with the male uh aging you know
superhero movie where you know the young
boy wants to look up to someone older
that's that's more established what's
going on in these groups uh you mean in
our production offices like when we're
discussing these films or you mean more
in a general sense more in a general
sense where are you getting the
information in terms of what the
audience wants how do you know that they
want all this I get this information
from data a lot of data of what movies
get uh Revenue in and which movies do
not um which movies my foreign buyers
respond to and which ones they don't
which movies domestic TV channels pay
attention to and which ones they pass on
and it's surprising the movies that cost
very little that uh don't you know have
much to really offer uh sometimes get
really big sizable uh price tags from
major TV channels uh here in the US and
overseas for a writer to really you know
have one of those opportunities it's
it's not guessing what people want it's
just being true to the story being true
to the characters um and I'm and writing
for the green light does not talk at all
about the craft of screenwriting that's
not my space my spa you know there's
fantastic books there's numerous College
professors who can speak to that much
better than I can but I can tell you
what works I can tell you what sells um
so how to get into the mindset of a
character it's just being responsive to
what you see in the real world and not
letting the story get ahead of what a
character would do if anybody has
brothers or sisters um if anybody has
children children uh just just you can
try to present something to them uh like
an idea of maybe what you know we could
do as a family or anything else and
you'll just notice they will react in
ways you don't expect them to and that's
what character should do too and uh
Universal themes always are the only
thing that will keep that all cohesive
so how to get into the mindset of a
Coming of Age male actor you just have
to look at what the main audience is
like who the main audience is and what
is it that they hope to get out of the
movie we talked about like if you're
going to a grocery store and you're
purchasing a box of cereal something
like that you're purchasing because you
you you want that taste you want that
flavor it's attractive to you you know
what you're getting at the end of the
day um a movie actually follows the same
mindset people want emotional
experiences and so if the demo is males
of this age or girls of this age uh you
have to you're not showing you don't
want to hold up a mirror and show them
reality you want to show them a Fant a
fantasy of what could be uh and a
reflection of what they hope it it looks
like on the other side that's you're
giving them you're giving them an
experience so get into their mindset of
not who they are what do they want to
see giving people what they want is
really the answer right so one step up
from where they already are yeah
interesting you talked before about
women and parel thrillers that you
notice most of them are upper middle
class right well that's because the
average audience is middle class lower
middle class and they they fantasize
about what that side of the tracks looks
like young girls identify with the main
protagonist of a twen girl film who's
kind of a little bit awkward a little
bit shy a little bit unsure of herself
because that's how most twins feel males
and females so they look up to those
characters who can move past that by
just being themselves and that's why
that genre works really well the
Creature Feature it's the same deal the
the male comeback Action Hero it's the
same deal the male comeback Action Hero
is fantastic cuz it's a it's a male
action hero who's given up up that
lifestyle and then gets forced into it
and I think that's as a middle-aged man
you want to kind of have that dream
fantasy scenario you could be a Dolph
lungren going back in and you know doing
some crazy missions in a foreign country
or something so per se you never have
like a full focus group where you sit
down women ages 35 to 45 who make this
much money per year and say which of
these scenes resonated with you most
it's never been I've never been a part
of that uh I think writers can do I
think writers have the best capability
of learning those skill sets by by
taking acting classes or improv classes
and learning how actors and how other
people will see a script who aren't
writers uh we have those focus groups
internally as a company by looking at
what our clients want because a a TV
channel in the Middle East or in London
or or in Japan they know what Their
audience wants they know what tween
girls respond to in Tokyo uh and so
they'll tell us we really like it when
films do this and if enough of those
triggers line up we know we need to
start seeing that in movies um as a
writer how do you get there again you
can't guess the trends you can't guess
those factors so just write really true
honest twing girl films or or coming of
age male action films dog Christmas
films any of the gold mine genres
spelled out and writing for the green
light just write any of those in a
universal true way um and you know you
will get the script will get noticed and
your talent will get noticed and then
you become pegged as a person that can
be communicated with to write the
scripts that these companies need that's
the idea of it your first couple scripts
out of the gate they're a business card
they're showcasing what you bring to
Hollywood that you understand what
Hollywood needs and it needs these kinds
of films to function so once you know
that and you present that and you show
consistency that you can deliver that uh
when the other side of the table goes
okay you passed the test you seem to
know what we want uh this is what we
need written can you do it and that's
how it really
kickstarts when a movie is brought to a
television distributor uh what type of
Advance should a filmmaker expect all
over the map if
uh all over the map there are films that
it's becoming more and more common that
films are are represented on a revenue
share which is just a split of
percentages there's a lot of situations
where uh an upfront called the minimum
guarantee or mg is paid and that can be
a good faith mg of 10 $15,000 it can be
a massive mg of 100 200 sometimes
$400,000 If All rights are being
Acquired and then percentages on the
back end there can be an outright
purchase which is really really high uh
the story that most people know from the
90s and the Sundance ERA with uh you
know when the Weinstein were mirax and
not the Weinstein Company um it was the
idea that you could an independent could
bring a movie to the marketplace place
that no one had ever heard of before
that there's no cast names in it or
anything like that and that like huge
dollars would just be put down on it
that's a different era it doesn't exist
today films are not marketed the same
way today um and so the value of films
is completely different and besides
technolog is dramatically increased so
uh with advances in technology films are
much cheaper to produce more people are
producing them there's a huge
overabundance of films out there and so
the value of of putting down large sums
of money has actually gone down quite a
bit so in a very short answer it's all
over the map uh it depends who's in it
depends what genre it is depends the
quality uh
depends if it's fully deliverable if the
movie is not fully deliverable like if
it doesn't have all the the legal
elements on the back end that's
problematic and it's a deal breaker um
and I I have some other writings that
I'm putting together on that specific
point actually about how to make a film
deliverable um these are all elements
that can put the price tag of what a
movie is worth to a production company
in completely different quadrants and
I'll tell you this we we run very very
detailed analytics on every film so when
we review a film we will have it
screened by several different people um
and we do compensations to other
projects we do very detailed assumptions
projections of what we think the film is
worth and so when we give uh percentages
and price tags on movies uh we've done a
lot of research to come up with those
numbers and it has to be incentivizing
to us and it has to be incentivizing to
the producer and uh you know we put a
lot of calculation into finding that
middle ground and this is all like
computerized data it's watch time and
where someone may have dropped off and
it's it's all in that and it's also um
yeah it's all in that and it's also just
in general
like experience of uh knowing how films
move you know I've been in international
sales for a long long time I've been in
domestic sales in North America for a
long long time I've been in meeting
rooms and presented projects and I've
seen faces wise up when I present a
project that I thought would sell really
well and I've seen excitement over
projects I didn't think stood a chance
and I've developed a very good barometer
about what movies work what what doesn't
work uh as has anyone in this business
who's been around for a while you just
you learn what makes sense what moves
the needle and what doesn't and so all
of those are factors into what gives a
film a price teag so when a producer
has this wild assumption that his movie
is worth $500,000 $2 million or
something ridiculous when it's just not
um if he's getting offers that are just
Revenue shares or very very very small
MGS there's a very logical rational
mathematical answer to
why